here is Anthony fauci yesterday
apparently Chris Cuomo from CNN you saw
his brother Andrew Cuomo there the
disgraced former governor of New York
although everything being equal he was a
hell of a lot better than this crazy
woman Kathy Ocho well he got booted from
New York and Chris Cuomo got booted from
CNN but these people keep appearing like
weeds you can't stop him so fauci went
on Cuomo's show and finally cuovo who
was all for lockdown's hiding
information about his brother and the
the nursing homes and all that stuff
suddenly now he's independent so now
he's he's getting some balls but if you
treated people more as adults Tony sorry
to interrupt but have you treated people
more as adults I mean like look
we don't know 100 I think it's better if
you have a mask
um it's better if you keep some distance
but I don't really know uh if we had
treated people like adults
and giving them the information as
qualified like you guys do about
everything else in our medical lives
nobody gives you 100 of anything
everything's percentages
don't you think maybe we would have
avoided the lockdowns that we would have
avoided some of the more Extreme
Measures because people would have been
told all along listen this is a you know
this is a dicey proposition we don't
really know about these things
I have to disagree with You Chris I love
you but I got to disagree with you go
ahead of course
the fact is that by saying you don't
know doesn't really change whether or
not you're going to lock down lockdowns
got a bad reputation but remember when
we put a pause on things for 15 days and
then an additional 30 days it was out of
time when the hospital system in New
York was being overrun and the only way
you stop that is by essentially stopping
the virus in its tracks you can do that
by locking down but lockdown has to be
the last resort and it can never be
permanent
okay so there's so much nonsense there
and fauci probably should end up in jail
if there is Justice here uh first off
when the hospital systems in New York
were being overrun where is the video
anywhere in the world of hospitals that
were overrun with deaths nowhere in
Africa where maybe their clean water
isn't as clean uh where that you know
somewhere in Eastern Europe where their
practices are a little bit different
than ours where are any of the hospitals
where's one city in the United States
where's the back uh the back water place
in Alabama that they're just really
backwards rednecks according to these
people that didn't clean their hands and
everything else where the whole town was
taken out why is there no video of that
anywhere and then at the end that he
dare he dare say the last option is
lockdowns that was the first option for
them remember two weeks to slow the
spread that was the first thing they
decided and the vaccines didn't work and
the lockdowns didn't work and The Masks
didn't work fauci had the gall you may
remember this just two or three months
into this thing when he's demanding
everyone masking literally on air he's
talking about double masking a friend of
his asks us emails him these emails have
come out a friend of him asked I think
they were going to Mexico do the kids
have to wear masks and he says they
basically don't work because you know
mask when you put a mask on you're still
getting air this way and air this way
and all of this stuff so everything he
says is a lie and he's just trying to
save his ass